và giám ngụi bây giờ người hoàn lưu sau bảo sống mềm bột đáng cây mưa vừa đến người rất to ở vụ cuộc khả nội.
Cơ quan chỉ tự sự báo người ở tụ đô cập kia gài trong sáng bây tình buổi.
Và kẹn báo ngụ cân nhập lụ các thím dường,
cho các quan chỉ tự vụ mưa kia gài trong sống dường.
Ý đêm đến khoảng hình bây tình buổi phục viến từ năm vừa đến một chắc lươi mẹc.
Con người cao người như chạm sắc sơ của chắc nâm như gài thứ hai người đến mẹc.
Chạm để chỉ một chắc thấy hai người đến mẹc.
Sự báo trong sáng bây tháng mưa tiếp tục có mưa vừa mưa tò và giông.
Lựng mưa vụ biến từ năm mưa đến một chắc lươi mẹc.
Bộ có nơi người rất to trên một chắc nâm như đi đến mẹc.
Này rất cầm để phòng viết cơ sây ra nập uống gài cắt tuyến phố chống khắp trong người thành.
Hơn nước này sẽ đoàn gập tính cộng bộ trong bù sư tình phố,
bởi đổi sông nập lế nhất của biến từ khó kể hai đêm khó kể buống mẹc.
Họ nơi nập sống hơn, tây ra nập khoảng tự buổi đình bà dơ có nơi nập lông hơn.
Lời sân tụi đô có thể tham khảo sáng xác các liện điểm có mi cơ ngọt uống gại thành phố Hàn đổi tại địa chi.
Hát tây tây tây thác nước Hàn đổi trầm về nơ, cơ cháo uống mập.